[Musique]
normes comme l'âme de la canne à sucre
groupe de talentueux musiciens comme ce
qui est chose multi instrumentiste
d'origine haïtienne
jacob c'est quelqu'un que j'ai beaucoup
écouté beaucoup écouté sa musique et
avec kassav et son album solo et phrases
infected un plaisir pour moi de
participer à ce moment pour moi est
historique
[Musique]
harmonica et au chant gerica chaque
stade
ex choriste de feu johnny hallyday et de
mylène farmer
[Musique]
jouer
j'étais très surprise quand jacob m'a
appelé parce que je suis je fais
beaucoup de soul music et de rythm and
blues et je me dis mais comment on va
relier marié rendre en symbiose lezoux
de jacob et le blues et de jazz beaucoup
mais comment lors de son fait mais pour
nous a vus before penser à 10 mois
by antho l'humanité on sent un petit
recharger le symbole interprété avec ses
amis musiciens
on se connaît tous en fait on se connaît
même si on travaille pas tout le temps
ensemble où c'est arrivé qu'on ait
travaillé ensemble par exemple mario on
a travaillé ensemble en 81
10 308 et 90 pour les premiers grands
méchants loups par exemple jaoui ont ces
rencontres et aux îles du cap vert avec
mario et thierry fanfant faire avec
d'autres musiciens
et à chaque fois je dis mais il faudrait
pour faire des trucs l'ensemble et mais
bon c'est mon planning to ce circuit
c'est pas toujours évident mais en tout
cas on finit des fois par ce gros croisé
à ça se fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jacob nous révèle ainsi sa vision du
blues au chrtr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lundi j'ai lancé vous casse un petit
bijou possible grâce aux tic
puis j'ai aussi passé par là
on valide en vigueur
norma comme nouveau concept nouvelle
aventure peut-être que le très très
longues années
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]